finish this sentence for me phoebe
bridgers makes music for
people who aren't in therapy yet
hi how are you phoebe i'm great how are
you i love you
i was like phoebe bridgers has a
skeleton onesie so i'm gonna wear
a skeleton wendy in your honor it's so
great
do you know what you're gonna wear the
grammys are you gonna bring that scoop
the spooky or skeleton vibe
on sunday yes that's the plan um
something skeletony
i can't wear it for the whole thing and
plus i'm gay and love a costume change
so i'm going to keep this off
we do right exactly
let's talk about these grammy
nominations phoebe i'ma list them out
best rock performance best rock song
best alternative album
and best new artist i mean
congratulations uh what are you feeling
going into sunday
nervous i can't imagine it you know
i especially now with this wild
time that we're all in i have no idea
what it's going to be like you know
was being nominated and going to the
grammys kind of on your bucket list
definitely but probably not since i was
like 10 because it's hard to imagine
especially as an indie folk singer for
most of my records you know the fast
songs on my records are few and far
between
so definitely dreamed about it as a kid
but but didn't have any expectations as
an adult so it's it's
that makes it even better to have not
expected it now i hear you get to take
one person with you to the grammys who's
that person for you who's your date
my date is my little brother jackson
which is very
misleading because he's a lot taller
than me okay so you're tall little
brother
yeah that's so exciting you guys are in
for such a fun night i'm really excited
for you
i read somewhere that you said not
telling the truth
is exhausting so tell me the truth how
badly do you want to win a grammy or is
it really an honor just to be nominated
that's really what it like is so so much
it's just
wild to me that i'm nominated especially
with people i'm such a huge
fan of yeah like this year specifically
and the pandemic bringing us
for me personally closer to music that
comes out like i listen to everything
as it's coming out and so seeing my name
on a list with people whose
records i just was obsessed with is so
so cool
you are one of three lgbtq artists
nominated for best new artist
obviously i'm hoping for a date where
that's not such a headline but i am
curious knowing that you're one of three
in this huge category what does that
mean to you it means a lot
when i was a kid i clung to any
representation at all
i think we all love movies that seem
like queer movies that aren't like bend
it like beckham
and stuff like it's not a gay movie but
i was like it's a gay movie in my heart
so i think that not reaching so far for
it and there being more representation
is so meaningful
and it would have really helped me as a
kid so absolutely and think about
you helping so many kids now i mean does
that feel like a a weighted
responsibility no i mean it does feel
like a responsibility
but i feel like all i can really do is
tell the truth and then people who
resonate with me will find me i feel the
same way about my music
so much of that honesty and that answer
is also in your songwriting
[Music]
you know it's so raw it's so pure what
does it feel like to be celebrated for
literally cracking open your heart like
in your music and in your work it's wild
especially being alone all the time it's
very weird it's hard to really
feel but i'm excited to get on the road
and and feel it for real
are you ready to cry your eyeballs out
on stage a little bit
yes that'll be my new stage move every
night do you
have any clue of when you might be on
the road next at all
or has have those talks not even started
they haven't started for me
my my thinking on it is that someone
with more money to lose is probably
ripping their hair out right now
thinking about it my dream is to go into
a room and
and be covered and other people's sweat
again yes without fear of death
i agree i agree so what's next uh have
you been
writing and recording songs during the
pandemic
i wish i i have felt so uncreative
over the pandemic but i think i've
funneled that into my late night tv
performances and all the stuff that's so
different now
but i hope because there's been a dry
spell that my writing will kind of kick
off when you look back on this last year
what will you remember the most
well it's dangerous because all the days
kind of blur
together but the ones that stick out for
me
are kind of these like milestone moments
where a friend called me and said
they love my record or taking a
beautiful walk and going to the beach so
so it's kind of like a montage already
of amazing stuff
but getting a text from my mom about the
grammys and snl
it's just yeah it feels like five days
you know but i'll remember those five
days forever for sure